as scientists warn about the fragility
of our planet's climate at the un summit
in glasgow people around the world are
taking to the streets calling for
decisive action
crowds of concerned citizens joined
climate activists in the scottish city
to demonstrate for a second today
they're demanding drastic action to curb
global warming delegates from nearly
every country in the world are in the
city negotiating how to limit
temperature rises to 1.5 degrees celsius
but for activists even this could be too
little too late last night climate
activist greta tunberg described the
summit as a failure
and we asked protesters what message
they wanted to send world leaders at the
summit
um so we want um commitment
to
massive infrastructure
and jobs in healthcare and a green
transition and we want no more
investment and new fossil fuels as the
international energy agency has said by
the end of this year
start paying attention to climate change
and actually take real action
and i mean the two volts asked me to end
domestic flights i don't see the point
in getting planes from london to
scotland there's enough trains going
around so yeah a small target like that
i'd appreciate but
yeah on a global level they need to do
much more
the thing is they really have to act now
we want to be as loud as possible
because what's happening now is they are
putting the blame
or the responsibility for the climate
crisis on regular people or some people
like you and me
and we think it's really important to
attack the big polluting multinationals
who are the most responsible for climate
and for more let's cross over to dw
correspondent zara stefan who's in
glasgow zara what's been happening where
you are
um well on the streets of glasgow
there's a protest march going on right
now where right now we're towards the
end of it you can see cyclists for
climate change um that are lining up
here um you can hear them ringing their
bells
like there's a lot of people turned up
here despite the rain and heavy winds
and people here really want to make
their voices heard that leaders take
climate change seriously
and zara what are the people protesting
against what exactly do they want to
achieve today
i think i may have lost the connection
um their demand that leaders
keep to their promise to limit
climate change to 1.5 degrees celsius um
and that they actually make um more than
just pledges that they they stick to
promises they've made and that they that
they show us real real climate action
zara greta tunberg has already labeled
this summit a failure how do the
protesters feel about what they've seen
and what they've heard from world
leaders so far i can't hear
i can't hear anything um
could you so do you try again please
yeah zara's just asking what the
protesters make of what they've seen and
heard from world leaders so far well the
marsh is is going on throughout the city
of glasgow and then later on there will
be a rally where greta toonberg and
other climate activists like ugandan
climate activist vanessa nakata are
bound to speak richard toonberg
yesterday already called um this cop uh
26 a failure um and um
and it's it's it's quite clear that they
demand more more actions from from world
leaders
had a very loud climate protest in
glasgow thank you very much
well demonstrations are not just
happening in glasgow worldwide people
are calling for meaningful decisions at
the climate summit
in paris where the last cop meeting took
place protesters laid out canvas
portraits of world leaders asking for
them to take action
where is planet b protesters are asking
thousands also took to the streets of
london on what activists are calling the
global day of action for climate justice
and earlier in australia protesters
there called on prime minister scott
morrison or they called him rather an
absolute embarrassment for supporting
fossil fuel industries in australia